[Music]
be careful okay we need a call
we need to call for help get to the
airport and get out of here and i am
driving
okay call for call for help
where's your phone
okay
tell me you caught the protagonist
[Music]
it's loretta
what are you thinking
you might have killed one of them but
his partner's still with her and he is
clearly skilled
highly trained
and very dangerous
[Music]
so
miss sage said she was gonna leave the
event then got in a car and left the
event
did you try calling her she doesn't have
her phone stolen phone didn't say that
where's my magnifier listen can you
please help with nana i don't want
hearing about loretta cause it's going
to upset her what about loretta oh
nothing nana she just went on a trip oh
god yeah that girl needed to get out of
the house so this is the thing loretta's
phone is not stolen i took it and i gave
it to alan allen then gave it to the
trainer uh
jack
trainer and that is how we found her
wearable and uh who's alan dash what's
that he's the hero in all of her books
nana hey [ __ ] mm-hmm let's go in the
other room and talk about whichever war
you lived through okay come on it'll be
fun i'm sorry it'll be fun listen
loretta's sage is missing when i looked
at her smartwatches said that she had
flown to some i've never even heard
about so that means you all need to do
something about this and if you can't i
will and that won't look good for you
pretty sure that's outside our
jurisdiction you'd have to call the feds
okay
and if you do go to the feds put in a
good word for me
for us
what are you gonna do with the car back
together
we can
where did you say the phone was
passenger glove what passenger glove
compartment
oh my god
oh my god no phone no car was still
going to die
what is this boot to the jungle
well it's not exactly hiking but it's
fine i just figured your feet would be
killing you after wearing heels for this
long i don't know it's best we could do
there allison sorry
oh okay well thank you
here oh i got your cheese
you gotta stay hydrated so much they
didn't have glass bottles so we'll
definitely hold on to it and recycle
okay so
what we need to do is we need to find a
phone we need to call the authorities
and we need to wait here until somebody
comes and rescues us uh
this
this is the rescue no one else is coming
right
i'm the rescue it was originally just
gonna be me and then and then i was like
trainer should come and then oh
that's in peace
so
they're our best bet is to get to the
airport you see this road right here
from this area just take a little
shortcut through the jungle to the
through the road today you say shortcut
through the jungle yeah okay do you see
us
okay you are not dash and i'm not
lovemore okay i'm loretta and you are
alan and jungles eat people like us okay
and i don't want to mess up the jumpsuit
it's on loan so we're gonna
put we're not just gonna stand around
here okay we're gonna go through the
jungle we're gonna go to the airport and
find a phone so you can have your cake
and get what you want
and eat it too if that's what you wanna
do with your cake fine let's go that's
the only thing you do with cake not mine
i don't know what your people do my
people eat it you could give it to
someone as a gift those people are still
going to eat the cake everybody eats
cake what about the kind that people
jump out of they don't eat it when
they're in it oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
what did they kidnap before anyhow is it
like some weird sex stuff like taking oh
my god thank you i thought so too but
the guy's one of the fairfaxes beverly
no the older one the really odd one that
had like the vlog on finding montezuma's
treasure the dude that was on the news
we're trying to raise yes yes he's
looking for the crown of fire
wait a minute like the actual crown of
fire like the one
so those ruins were this lost city yeah
they're lost city of d yes what are you
kidding me right now
this is like your like like your book so
we're basically on like a love more and
dash adventure right now how what is
that wait what if what if fairfax
actually like finds the crown though oh
he he won't he won't
where do we go
okay
uh we need to get in the water what we
need
we need to go by river oh no no i don't
i don't really do water what do you need
to do water i'm not asking you to
procreate with it uh my body and water
don't really go together how do you feel
about dying
where are you going i'm crossing no we
have to stay in the water i researched
aquatic countertracking for my book and
you're in the bush and they'll lose our
traps in the water why is it warm here
wait are you peeing just go around it
so
[Music]
i think we lost them right
yeah that wasn't so bad
yeah
okay uh
don't panic what do we know pam don't
panic no don't stop saying panic you're
panicking you have something on your
back
what is that
stop screaming what is that what is that
do you have any on you no no wait why
don't you have anyone here the jumpsuit
scared him off i don't i don't know get
them all oh my god
no i can't touch this blood gorge mucus
sacks
can you why don't you just pick it and
fling it just pick it you pick it and
fling it can you spin it
oh get it oh i don't like touching it i
don't i'm feeling
[Music]
how many of them are there oh there's
not many nothing feels
i feel so many oh holy mother of god why
are you praying
what is this taken am i talking
alan i'm here to save you
ow
she is the key to finding the lost
treasure after them i am driving oh
what is that just pick it
up getting you out of here why are you
so handsome my dad was a weatherman the
lost city march 25th
[Music]
you